funny thing is i had this shirt on
before i read this news
so word has come down as to when we will
get to see
wonder woman 1984 and apparently that
will be
for christmas on hbo max and also in
theaters
in america uh releasing on that date now
this isn't all together unexpected
it's kind of it's started happening that
studios are drip feeding their release
their releases through
whatever they can work best i know
everyone had hoped the pandemic would
just be gone
uh by now but you know it's not and it
won't be
for a while the i don't want to get too
much into the weeds about
you know even if we have viable vaccines
fairly soon how long distribution is
going to take and everything else
even setting all that aside any
studio like warner brothers or disney or
paramount or universal or anybody
worth their salt they need to be
planning for 2021
as if theaters will not open the entire
year if they do
great work with that but they they
should be planning around the idea that
that won't happen
because they need to plan for the worst
case scenario at this point
so it's not shocking that more of these
things are starting to get
some form of release along these lines
because
if they just keep sitting on these
finished products they're not generating
any revenue they're just sitting there
so seeing it get a digital distribution
is not
all that shocking all things considered
uh
and it also probably helps at least a
little bit that in the case of wonder
woman 1984 it does seem to have um
you know from what i could tell looking
at the trailers and what i've read about
it was trying to go for some topical
commentary if they sit on it too much
longer it's not gonna be
relevant uh so that that might be
another factor going in but here's the
thing that made me decide i needed to
talk about it
because if it was just the release date
yeah i would have left it at that but
here's the thing it's being released on
hbo max
at no additional cost if you are
subscribed to hbo max
you just get to watch it come christmas
now this is interesting and kind of
important because it's in stark contrast
to the last big release that was
supposed to hit the theaters that we got
in the last few months which was of
course mulan over in disney plus
now that had caused a little bit of a
kerfuffle by
being a 30 buck rental
even on top of whatever it cost you to
have disney plus
in the first place so that was
that was a ballsy move on disney's part
and the thing is it might
even have paid off on the longer term
if mulan had been better received if
you're going to pull a move like that
you really need to be doing it with a
product where people are going to say
by the time the credits are rolling yeah
yeah you know what
that was worth the money unfortunately
nobody really seemed to like
the live-action mulan very much which
means disney really kind of burned that
bridge
and pretty much everybody realized no no
it wasn't worth it i mean even
families who when theaters are open
are taking three four people plus snacks
30 bucks in theory is actually probably
going to be less money than it would
cost them to go to the theater
but you don't just go to the theater for
the move to for the privilege of seeing
the movie early you go for the
experience
and when you're just having an at-home
experience paying what you would pay to
go to a movie theater ah
no that that didn't work and i think
here's the
thing i think disney realized they blew
they blew it and burned that bridge
also because they also have a movie
coming out
on december 25th which is pixar's soul
and that like wonder woman 1984
is being released just to whoever
already has disney plus
now a couple of things about all this
the first
is we should not be expecting
that this is going to be what a standard
these massive tentpole films that
used to be the kinds of things that we
would go to the theater for are just
going to be on streaming services now
that again to look at a worst-case
scenario where either the pandemic drags
on
for a year two years or whatever or
not if it's not that it drags on long
enough that enough
theaters close that even when theaters
are ready to reopen it's just not going
to see the kind of revenue returns that
it used to
what that means is we should not be
expecting to see
movies of the scale of wonder woman 1984
coming to streaming
too far going forward next year next
couple years
even maybe but the thing is the studios
have a bunch of these things that are
already shot
or it started production or had already
been budgeted at a certain thing
and they're gonna see them through as
they had planned them but the thing is
you don't
budget a 200 million dollar movie to
release to streaming
that's really bad economics right there
about as big as streaming
direct-to-streaming movies get
is maybe 70 million dollar range like
deadpool 1 money
not wonder woman sequel money but
as i said they can't just sit on these
things because they're not
generating any revenue if they just sit
on them so they are now starting to drip
feed and release them over time so that
they're at least getting
something in but they're not suddenly
gonna start making
movies of the scale for streaming if we
end up coming into a world on the other
end of this whole mess
where theatrical experience
becomes more niche or just smaller scale
or just doesn't have the
the foundation and the infrastructure to
infrastructure
to generate the same kind of revenue
anymore then what that means is if they
start making more things directly for
streaming it's just going to be lower
budget
so just understand that going in but i
also want to zoom back in on wonder
woman 1984 specifically because i think
there are other things at play as to
why um they decided to do
this one specifically because warner
brothers is
probably sitting on a couple of things
at this point that it could
uh have been considering releasing
but i think there's a fairly specific
element at play for
releasing wonder woman and releasing it
at the timing that they are
because remember how we uh we got a
quote-unquote new there wasn't actually
a lot new in it trailer for
uh the snyder cut for justice league
again
well you know there's more than a little
crossover in the audience of people who
are interested in seeing wonder woman
and people who are interested whether it
be because they think it'll genuinely be
good or because they're morbidly curious
in seeing justice league zack snyder's
justice league
and it's a really solid plan and
model to have wonder woman come out
and then have the time between that and
zack snyder's justice league be
several months but not so long that
people might not just go
you know what i'll just hold on to the
subscription until that comes out
this is why it was important for
hbo to have shows like westworld and
you know trying to have other really
hook people in zeitgeist shows
to show between seasons of game of
thrones
because while it's certainly not a bad
thing if people are subscribing to your
service
strictly for one show if they're not
subscribed during the months when that
show isn't airing well
then that's money you could have been
making but you didn't so you try and
have
stuff going on in the off times and this
is kind of a film equivalent of that a
little bit
because there's no doubt that
again whether it be genuine enthusiasm
or morbid curiosity it doesn't really
matter the money spends the same either
way
there's going to be a pretty heavy
influx of cash when
the snyder cut is eventually released
but think of how much more money they
could pocket if the people who are
planning to see the snyder cut who
weren't already subscribed
to hbo max go oh you know what maybe
i'll
i'll start in december so i can watch
wonder woman
and i'll just bum around there for a bit
until snyder cut comes out
um or failing that you know it might be
people who already have it or like it's
a reason to definitely go oh yeah you
you give people reasons to keep looking
forward to stuff
and they stick around longer
and i think it's also a pretty smart
idea because
to be blunt about it a lot more people
were genuinely excited for wonder woman
and look i know
i'm not expecting the snyder cut to be
good or at least not to my taste i'm not
trying to bad mouth that cut
but what you have to grant me is
snyder's take on the dc
properties has been heavily divisive
from the beginning so no matter what you
think of the movies he's done up to this
point or of his justice league when it
comes out
it is probably also going to be very
divisive
so it's a good idea to have
a big tentpole release that is something
that is
likely to have much wider appeal likely
to
go down well with a much higher percent
of percentage of your audience so that
they
subscribe get used to paying it over the
months and then by the time the snyder
cut comes out even if they don't like it
that much
they probably won't tune out because
suddenly that wasn't the only thing they
subscribed
for now like i said
how far down the line will continue to
see
movies of this scale get released to
streaming platforms it's hard to say
it's really going to depend on how long
the
pandemic continues to hit at the kind of
numbers it
has been and it also depends on
how many movie theaters are still up and
running when we get on the other side of
this whenever that is
because
i i think in a lot of ways what warner
brothers and now also disney are doing
which is just releasing their stuff on
their services at no extra cost is the
thing these studios have been
desperately trying to not have to do
but they're running out of options
because
warner brothers tried to get people back
in movie theaters to see tenet didn't
really work i mean it
yeah number one at the box office for a
bunch of empty theaters or closed
theaters
huge shock that didn't really work
disney tried their own thing by
charging a premium for mulan if it had
been a better
movie maybe that would have worked or at
least wouldn't have 100
burned that bridge but it totally did
they're out of options
and so releasing it at no extra cost now
especially at christmas it feels like a
gift
when in truth there are probably more
accurate say they've been
backed into a corner and are running out
of choices
for what to do with these things and
have to figure out
what is going to get us the best results
based off the situation we're in
none of us want to be in this situation
what do we do and under the
circumstances
from a business perspective at least as
best as i can sort of parse it
that's a smart move i'm i'm looking
forward to the movie
i'll probably i don't know if i'll see
it that day i'll probably see it the day
after at the latest
so wonder woman 1984 free on hbo max
come christmas
what do you think about that whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about usual
stuff
like share subscribe i have a patreon
and it keeps me fed
why am i singing i've no idea
and no particular tune
in any case thanks so much for
tuning in any amount you're able to help
the patreon is a great assistance but
you also don't have to
because at the end of the day my friends
you are the council
i a just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned and happy trans awareness
[Music]
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you um
[Music]